good day about fifty years ago I was a
student and worked with Gradstein Eirik
famous tables of integrals and series
and maybe at first time I worked on
major G function in this table oh my god
who can understand this horrible monster
so happens that in future years I worked
a lot with this monster and right now we
have in Mathematica system implemented
major function why it is monster I will
show later but we have single simple I
call functions like sine cosine or BSL
function and other and they are they
include parameters and maybe one or two
variables but if we go to more
complicated function to hypergeometric
functions we see lists of variables
hyper geometric way of Q function it has
two list of variables length a and Q it
is very big function which includes many
many particular cases including these
elementary functions and I can call this
function Monster Mathematica got
implementation of these functions many
years ago and basal function particular
case of this hyper geometric but blk is
not case completely because basic a
function with zero parameter it
is not belongs this hypergeometric for
description this ba said we need more
complicated when it in mayor G and you
see definition
you also see products of gamma functions
and it is for groups we serve it really
lends Amen PQ and in particular this
function includes about 100 named
functions and maybe all life I collect
tables of these functions this is my
first book was published about 40 years
ago and tried now it became today I had
from very non professor classical book
classical book and it has table of this
energy but currently I have four
thousand cases and they can convert to
mere reform in mathematical system what
does it mean it means that we can
somehow forget and ignore names about
100 functions and work with mayor G
because major complete different
functions like exponential type of
jabrai type piecewise and others yeah
let's walk on cases we can only eat
these cases and mayor J is used in
integration as I mentioned uniformity
because basically we can translate
function into merging form with major
Jerrod use you see in 2029 right now and
this
miyaji in active appeared inactive mayor
G but if we activate we return back
after function expand yeah and in
situation of these examples you see
several examples only right now we are
working to implement huge amounts of new
possibility for integration and for
Laplace transform for inverse Laplace
transform because in principle if we go
where is this Laplace transform yeah
okay if we make million transform from
Mayor G function we will get product of
gamma functions which you saw and if we
used convolution cerium we need to
multiply these products with as a
product gamma function for example we
heard from one original function v from
other 10 the gives a 15 and again we
saved the same class we will have
mirrors G with 15 functions and we need
to return back to original using
residual cerium this is main new engine
of such method which implemented is
system mathematical and I prepared very
large art talk but here we can discuss
details and I can show demonstration how
four thousand converts how work
integration in private talks with those
core are interesting and we
we have as a monster in our system
connected to his differentiation and
people does not know that there exists
uniformity huge monster in
differentiation which also cover a lot
each operation in differentiation what
kind operations we have for example
derivative order M from composition or
the N or serious expansion serious from
serious inverse serious physicists
permanently use these procedures and try
to find formulas in handbook but all
these formulas can be described by using
this one huge monster by name well why
and well why we implemented about five
years ago and this is a main specialist
in Bell I know Dan McDonald he made very
elegant general solution and numerical
ovulation which was implemented instead
other one which we had it was in time
when he was student in internship and I
will give him opportunity to continue
doc okay right so in the literature if
you look on Wikipedia or for Bell
polynomials you will probably be more
familiar with this first one this
partial Bell polynomial with these
indices in and K and then just a list of
input variables so this
is bail so this partial bail polynomial
is notable for several properties but
the one we'll discuss today is its use
in differentiation of composition of
functions so this comes this shows up in
fada bruno's formula which is nice it's
not slides not yeah
let's see what happens well yeah
there we go they do yeah it's let's get
a 150 okay so we all remember the chain
rule from calculus for differentiating a
composition of functions and so in
Mathematica we can do that symbolically
and so to generalize the chain rule we
have kind of two directions we can
either allow higher-order derivatives
which is what we'll do now or later
we'll see what happens if we allow
composition of more than just two
functions so if we allow higher-order
derivatives then this generalization of
the chain rule is known as fade of
Bruno's formula and so here you see one
way of expressing fade of Bruno's
formula is through this sum involving
these partial bail polynomials so here's
what it looks like for the third
derivative of f of G of Z so this is our
implementation of fate of Bruno's
formula and here is just Mathematica D
function and they give the same thing
which is good because otherwise fade to
Bruno died in vain I guess you didn't
actually die due to this I guess it
anyways so the Wolfram language now
actually thanks to Devon drew did he
show up is he here
he might be coming later now uses fate
of Bruno's formula for if we input a
unspecified higher order derivative of a
functional comp use it composition so
here we're taking derivative of F of G
of X but we're taking the nth derivative
where we don't know what n is but we
still
we still output this is formula based on
fate of Bruno's formula but if we
generalize the chain rule and that
otherwise speaking about by adding a
composition of a third function we see
the results get kind of unwieldy because
we're basically you know applying fate
of Bruno's formula a second time which
adds in another summation and these
formulas quickly become kind of useless
so that's why we had these generalized
Bell polynomials so here we input a we
input a matrix to our Bell Y function
and one definition you'll see is this
you know very complicated summation and
you'll notice this fabulous Bell wide
pond they did in my table naming
convention so you'll you know see the
output here so another Bell wide pond is
you know why does it have this kind of
crazy definition because really it was
reverse engineered to express the int
derivative of a composition of M
functions so basically it's what happens
if you apply fado bruno's original
formula m minus 1 times so the kind of
you know the thing to know about these
generalized Bell Y functions is that if
you put as input these derivatives of
functions evaluated at these
compositions of functions like this then
you get the in derivative of the
composition of functions
so this generalized Bell polynomial
generalizes the chain rule in both ways
you can have arbitrarily high
derivatives and arbitrarily deep
compositions of functions so right right
so here we we make a table by just doing
our straightforward higher order
derivative using the D function and then
we can see I'm using these generalized
Bell polynomials we we get the same
thing for for these higher order
derivatives of compositions you also
might have noticed a slide ago there was
a kind of an intermediate generalized
partial bail polynomials which we won't
really talk about today but let's make
this smaller yeah there we go I was
double clicking this is these can be
defined in terms of this larger general
bail polynomial so the last thing I'm
going to talk about is kind of a quick
way to compute these generalized bail
polynomials using kind of their meaning
as this means of differentiating these
compositions of functions so you know
thinking of the kind of the definition
of these polynomials in terms of
differentiating the composition of
functions we can notice that composition
is associative so we can really split up
the composition of functions any way we
want so we we can instead of having M
functions we can have here we have it
looks like P functions or yes
where we group the first M one together
then
group the next m2 together and so on so
that gives us this functional identity
where we're just recursively using the
this definition of bell Y on these sub
matrices so in terms of a means for
computing computing Bell Y looks like
we're gonna make this yes right we can
basically cut the partition the this
composition of functions into two
equally sized sequences of function so
f1 through F M over two and then F M
over 2 plus 1/2 F sub M and apply this
functional functional identity and so
this suggests a recursive program for
computing the these generalized Bell
polynomials and
so so basically we we can pad the matrix
with with these columns that represent
the identity function since the if you
compose with the identity function
you're not changing anything till we get
to a power of two till we get M as a
power of two and then we have an
implementation of fade of Bruno's
formula for a matrix having exactly two
columns that's this line here and then
we apply fade of Bruno's formula
successively until we're down to just
one column of the matrix and then we
once were at the last column we take the
the last element that column and that's
the nth derivative of our composition of
M functions so if we run this little
function here then we can have this you
know pretty big random matrix and we
should get the same results with this
kind of ad hoc del Y function and
eventually the mathematical function
should give the same thing good okay so
I think Oleg wanted to talk a little bit
more about I want to add very important
notes you just saw that bell Y satisfied
compositions rules and if instead wet
Bell why we use major G major Z
transform it is integral transform like
in particular huncle transform
fractional integral Laplace transform
inverse Laplace transform silkiest
transform a and many other transforms
classical transforms all these
transforms is integral transforms is
major G transform
cases of Maori transform and inverse to
these transforms also mirzee type
transforms we studied this in this book
which was published about 30 years ago
Cuba's some Cuba's mothership integral
fractional integrals and derivatives
para chapter 2036 includes theory of
these compositions of million of mirror
Z transforms so again know for example
we can take normal distribution it is
also not normal how to say no usual
distribution with exponential function
and exponential function consists to
corresponds to one mir-21 gamma function
exponential function in my language
Mirian which corresponds to gamma
function if we take composition of this
we produce product of these gamma
functions this product you can see
inside of definition beer function so
composition will be again a mere
transform and all rules in sense
composition decomposition inversion for
this mere transform similar to what we
hear right now about Bill Y so basically
we have two monsters one cover
integration as a differentiation and you
did not talk about examples like how to
relate inverse series using bill y how
to relate composition of
or ratio from serious and many in worth
serious and many are separations
function in degree function integral
function we can make derivative of this
using the Y we can expand in serious
everything that can be doable we have
formulas which not presented in talk but
you can find in my collections thank you
[Applause]